CLIFF REDEKER: How's
everybody doing today?
Good morning and welcome
to another exciting Talks
at Google event.
I'm Cliff, but the real
star of our conversation
here today is Ekta Kapoor, so
please welcome her to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
EKTA KAPOOR: Thank you.
Thank you.
CLIFF REDEKER: Now
she can clearly
be described as India's
number one media mogul.
She has production experience--
over 15,000 hours of content,
and that number is
growing on a daily basis,
as we'll talk about during
our conversation today.
She's constantly changing
the face of media in India.
Under her leadership,
Balaji Telefilms
has expanded to include the
Balaji Motion Pictures, ALT
Entertainment Limited,
Bolt Media Limited,
and the popularity
continues to grow.
She's topped ratings
on TV for decades,
especially with soap operas
and serials such as the "Kyunki
Saas Bhi Kabi Bahu Thi."
[LAUGHING]
I had to-- I had to
practice my Hindi
before I brought in this Talk.
And also we have the
"Kahaani Ghar Ghar Kii,"
the "Hum Paanch"--
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry, I-- it's getting better.
EKTA KAPOOR: They sound
way better with you.
Please continue.
CLIFF REDEKER: Thank you.
Thank you.
And then several
blockbuster films, including
the "Shootout at Lokhandwada."
EKTA KAPOOR: Wala.
CLIFF REDEKER: Wala.
So close.
"Ragini MMS" and then
"The Dirty Picture."
I'm able to get that one done.
[LAUGHING]
And we'll have time for some
brief Q&A towards the end,
so be on the lookout
for a microphone
as it circulates around.
But I just wanted to start out
by you're here in the Bay Area.
What brings you to town?
What have you been
up to recently?
EKTA KAPOOR: So actually--
two different questions,
but I'll answer both.
We were about to
organize a BCL cricket
match, a totally different
experience for anyone who
watches television with TV
stars playing out cricket
with women and men playing TV.
It's an interesting form.
I just added
[INAUDIBLE] this year.
What a fabulous response.
Great ratings.
So we decided-- it's an
event based TV gameshow,
so I can do it off
television in a studio
so the game can be watched live
or then watched on television.
So we're planning
to do it again,
because we had some visa
issues and we couldn't do it.
But I said, let's
not cancel the trip,
and come and reassure
our viewers here
that we're going to do it soon.
CLIFF REDEKER: And so
has that been a challenge
or a difference for
you, moving away
from the more drama
and fiction-based shows
to this sporting event?
EKTA KAPOOR: So I'm
as far from sports
as probably Sachin
Tendulkar is from dramas,
but I had no option.
But when this concept came
to me with all the television
stars with women and
men playing cricket,
especially with the growing
interest in women for cricket,
I was like, why not do it.
Because it's not the love of the
game, but the love of equality
that made me enjoy
the whole game.
Women are playing it as well.
I love it when a
female television
actress gets a guy out.
There's so much
sledging out there.
So if you see the
game live, you'll
actually be shocked because
people forget that known TV
stars, they start sledging
each other, especially
the male actors.
And at the end, you're all
rooting for the women for them
to get the guys out.
So it's interesting, fun.
It's exciting.
It's a whole new concept, and
I thought enjoyed cricket way
more when I saw it this way.
CLIFF REDEKER:
Well, hopefully you
can bowl a few rounds yourself.
EKTA KAPOOR: As
far as-- I managed
to hit the bat when
Sunny Deol bowled,
and I think I did
a pretty good job,
but that's because I have some
experience of playing squash.
But as far as dramas go,
I continue doing drama.
Actually, that's
the thing I know,
and I probably only
know two things in life.
One is probably making
tea, [INAUDIBLE] green tea,
and the second is dramas,
so I can't leave it.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well, the
success continues to follow.
And I was hoping for the
folks in the audience
and the folks on YouTube
if you could give me
a little bit of background to
the origins of your production
company.
It sounds like many
great things, like Google
and up and down the
street here, you
started in a garage, which
I thought was pretty cool.
EKTA KAPOOR: Yes.
So the year I was about 16 years
old and extremely overweight.
No interest, unlike
many other star kids,
to join films as an actress.
Not that anyone would take
me with that kind of weight,
but I didn't have any
interest myself also.
And all I wanted to do was tell
stories or become a journalist
or do something interesting.
Television was in its
nascent stage at that time,
and my dad offered me to
make television programming
for a friend of his who
had a channel in the UK
called TV Asia.
So I sat down.
I started making the
programs, and the channel
got sold to Zee.
So I had three shows
and no channel.
So I said, let's try to sell it
here, and none of it got sold.
Made some more shows, and
after about four years
of struggle, real
struggle, I [INAUDIBLE]
hitting it with one of the
channels, Zee in India,
with "Hum Paanch."
And then four or five years
of more struggle, and I
ended up doing a show
called "Kyo Kii,"
and then I just took off.
I think that's that
Eureka moment that
happens when you say, OK.
OK, now it's happening.
Oh, wow.
It's happening.
CLIFF REDEKER: It's real life.
And the other thing
that surprised me,
too-- it's a family
business, but in contrast
to many family
businesses in India,
it's a mother-daughter deal.
So how did that come
about, and what's
it like working
with your mom who
herself as a storied career?
EKTA KAPOOR: So my mom was
a housewife, ran a shop.
Completely star wife.
I was 16.
My dad was probably one of
the most emancipated fathers.
He was like, you must work.
You must do something
with your own life.
And he gave us a
little bit of capital
and said, do something now.
My mom, who had no idea about
business, got him to help me.
And both of us started, and
we made a business out of it.
I think it's important
for parents-- I mean,
we don't even realize how
smart our mothers are when they
manage the budget of the house.
I think that knowledge
helped her manage.
Today, she's known as one of
the best women in production
in India.
But it's as simple
or as complicated
as managing a budget
of a house, she says.
She says that gave her the
ground knowledge of how
to run a business, and it
was probably-- even today,
she takes extremely
strong and keen interest
in the house budget, because
she says it refines her skills.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah.
Yeah, and if the
house is not in order,
then it's hard to
keep the empire going.
And of course,
Tusshar, your brother,
also successful
in his own right.
Was there sibling
rivalry growing up
when you have two
sibling in the industry?
EKTA KAPOOR: He's an actor
and I'm actually a producer,
so there was really no rivalry.
But he's a simpler person.
He's not too ambitious.
He is now a father.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah, I heard.
EKTA KAPOOR: Yeah.
And he's given us the biggest
joy of our life, my nephew.
And I think I've
never had-- I mean,
not many people know this, but
I've been in awe of my brother.
I actually think he's a smarter,
saner, more stable person
than me.
I'm all over the
place, you know.
I could be good in one
thing-- that is business--
but I don't have the kind
of balance he has in life.
CLIFF REDEKER: But
at the same time,
it's a very family-- like
your family's very close-knit.
You know, you were
telling me before, you're
taking care of your nephew,
like, everybody's getting
together for home-cooked meals.
How do you keep that
sense of family while
at the same time dealing with
the ever-growing business?
Are you always talking about
the business, or about--
EKTA KAPOOR: So I don't
think being close-knit
as a family means spending
family time, too much of it,
you know?
Once or twice a week, we have
lunch or dinner together.
Most of the time, we're
working, but we're always
connected to each other.
And of course, we
all have duties
as far as my nephew goes.
And we all take it
up so you can do
what you want in your
business, but when
it's your time to take
care of your nephew,
it's that that takes over.
So there's like clearly--
I mean, everything else
takes a backstage.
But more than
anything else, I think
my family was the reason
I got into business.
I mean, they gave
me a lot of support.
I'm too lazy to move out.
I can't live alone.
It's not my scene.
I mean, having a house with--
CLIFF REDEKER: Right.
Right.
EKTA KAPOOR: --home-cooked
meals-- I'm not giving it up.
I can't go home and now
check-- like while my mother is
damn good at checking
the house budget,
I'd be a disaster at it.
I'm, like, probably the only
person who lives in the house.
Like, mom's says you're
living in a hotel.
You don't know anything
that's happening.
So I'm like one of those people
who waltzes in two o'clock
after work, get fresh food, be
happy about it, and pass out.
So I will never live alone.
CLIFF REDEKER: That's cool.
And then I'm also curious
to learn a little bit more
about your production
cycle for serials in India.
I'm a little--
admittedly a little bit
more familiar with how
they work in America,
but it seems like the volume
is just that much higher.
So--
EKTA KAPOOR: Yeah.
CLIFF REDEKER: --how do you
keep track of all the episodes?
EKTA KAPOOR: So it's constantly
checking on the episodes
here and there.
I go through the story
lines constantly.
There are many of us
which are doing very well.
There's one called "Kasam,"
"Ye Hai Mohabbatein,"
and, of course, "Naagin," which
created a whole new era as
far as ratings go.
What I'm doing now is
because the global Indian,
the city Indian, is very
different from the mass Indian.
And while we're making
television for the mass Indian,
for the global Indian
and for the urban Indian,
we're creating this app
which is going to start
at the end of the year.
[INAUDIBLE] this side of
the town, of the country,
of-- in Frisco
last December, when
it was really cold in Frisco
which is quite shocking.
And I had come to raise
funds, which I got.
And I'm now about
to start my app
in November, which is going to
be high-impact, shorter series.
13 to 20 episodes at max.
Multilingual, so
Tamil, Punjabi--
all different
languages, plus Hindi.
Hinglish also.
And it's going to create
content for the urban Indian who
doesn't have that
much time but wants
to watch high-impact,
good quality content,
like a longer elongated
film, but 13 episodes instead
of watching a daily
soap every day.
More individual viewing,
more urban in its taste,
more with urban issues
coming into place.
No multitasking.
Stuff that we don't deal with.
Because while
television has become
one size fits all, which is for
the extremely smaller towns who
like stories which are very,
very basic because they're
very, very simple in their
days, the urban, slightly more
complicated, slightly
more emancipated Indian
will now get content for
them in their language
with their thought
processes on the app.
CLIFF REDEKER: And that's
something that's really true.
I mean, with the
success of your serials,
it's a cultural phenomenon.
People throughout the country
are-- they know them by name.
To what extent are you shaping
culture versus reflecting
the culture that you see?
EKTA KAPOOR: I don't know
if I"m shaping culture.
I've had a lot of men tell
me that we don't get food
when your shows air, which
means I'm quite happy.
I say then go and
get your own plate.
Let her watch.
But yes, I actually believe
I-- I'm an observer.
I love human beings.
I love people.
I think while myself I'm very
private, I like to see people,
notice how they live.
I notice small, small things.
How people are at home.
I never lived in a joint
family, but I made all my shows
about joint family.
It was a labor of
aspiration, of how
life would be if I was in
a full or joint family.
It was also a little bit
of noticing friends' homes.
And then, of course,
it was about the fact
that a lot of women
in India are told
to take over their place
of their mother-in-law.
And it's easy to give
everything to your son,
because if I'm a man,
I give to my son.
But a woman is told to give
to a new girl who comes
to the house, and
we call it-- like,
every mother-in-law and
daughter in law have friction--
CLIFF REDEKER: Right. right.
EKTA KAPOOR: --have
friction, because
of the social
expectation put on women.
As a daughter-in-law,
I'm supposed
to accept this whole
family as my own.
And as a mother-in-law,
I'm supposed
to accept a new person.
Even your own body, when
you get a foreign body part,
it takes time to adjust.
So But men don't
have to do that.
And we see that
women have problems.
CLIFF REDEKER: And that's--
[LAUGHING]
And that's a recurring theme
through many of your shows,
so that's pretty cool.
You know, looking at
production-- like you said,
you've directed.
You've produced.
What aspect is your
favorite, and what--
EKTA KAPOOR: Writing.
CLIFF REDEKER: --sort of takes
you the most time to learn?
EKTA KAPOOR: Writing.
I think every time write a
new character or a new person,
I write knowing their
taste, where they come from,
how they are, how
their family life is,
how their romance will be.
How every time there's
a Cinderella story,
I feel I'm living that emotion
again with this new character.
I think I love writing.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, nice.
And then is there-- do you write
some things that don't make it
into the show eventually?
Like, are you writing long
biographies of these characters
that-- just to set the scene?
EKTA KAPOOR: I
don't think-- yeah.
I think eventually,
sometimes what
you write never comes on air.
But at the end of the
day, you have to know it.
When you're writing
a character, you
have to know where
they're coming from.
You may never use
that information,
but you have to know it.
You just have to mark
the journey better.
We all are a product
of our experiences.
CLIFF REDEKER: Are you
creating characters--
are you creating
characters for actors,
or are you bringing actors
to become your characters?
EKTA KAPOOR: I never create
characters for actors,
except for [INAUDIBLE], who
I have created characters
for because I think
she's a brilliant actor.
And there are times when
I've created-- I often think,
OK, this actor will have to
play and sometimes I waited.
But 95% of the time, I
just create the character.
I'm almost like how a
doctor sees an audition.
I just see an
audition as blankly.
I hate nepotism,
so I don't know who
the person is in front of me.
I don't find out about anybody
or work what they've done.
I just see the
character, and I feel
actor I feel OK, this person--
you just know it instinctively
if they'll suit your show.
I think that's the reason most
drama actors have so easily fit
in as a glove with
the character.
Because, I mean, when I
saw Divyanka's audition,
I didn't know what
she had done before.
But I knew that she
has to be Ishita.
Same for all the
other characters.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
your shows touch
on a wide variety of
subject matter and really
weighty and heavy
issues, too, so how
do you choose which subjects
to address in your serials?
EKTA KAPOOR: So I feel like
television is so much writing--
you're writing an episode
a day for every show--
that there's enough
scope to actually explore
all aspects of a person
or a story with humor.
Sometimes you get
extremely dramatic.
extremely shock-oriented.
But at the same time,
you play a lot of humor
in shows, because I think
there's so much time
and to plan out
these stories, then
you'll end up doing all of it.
CLIFF REDEKER: OK, cool.
And then I also wanted to
shift a little bit more
to the state of the
industry in India.
Like, where do you
think it's going?
You already talked about
the need to segment shows
for the folks living
in metropolitan areas,
rural areas.
There's obviously a global
audience these days.
What do you think is next
for your industry to conquer?
EKTA KAPOOR: So as I
said, most consumption
is now happening on
the digital television.
And appointment viewing
and family viewing
is becoming more like
a time oriented thing.
I don't want to watch two hours,
but I'd rather not watch TV.
I'd rather spend it having
dinner with my family.
TV viewing or
episode consumption
is becoming more
individualistic,
except in small
towns, especially
for the global
[INAUDIBLE] on the move.
I have an hour.
I'll go to my mobile,
check the last episode
of "Orange is the New
Black" or "House of Cards,"
and then I move on with life.
So with that being
individual viewing,
I don't have to actually watch.
Like I did a show a year
and a half ago in India.
I thought it was
really nicely made.
It was about second chances,
about a woman moving on
after having a very bad
marriage and getting
just friendly with this man
who comes into her life.
It didn't work,
because 80% of India
couldn't watch it
with their husbands.
So it became tough
for them, saying
that we want to watch the show,
but every time, my husband
says, why are you
watching this show?
So, I mean, the show died
due to a lot of insecurity.
But I realized that it would
be a perfect show for the app,
because it's individual viewing.
You can watch a
story on your own.
CLIFF REDEKER: And then the
other side of online viewing,
of course, is binge
watching and watching
more than one episode at once.
EKTA KAPOOR: Absolutely.
You just watch a story
at one go, finish it off,
then hopefully wait
for the next season.
Or then, say, after
four episodes,
you don't want to watch it.
But-- yeah.
So you don't have to
watch half hour every day,
and it doesn't have
to be 100 episodes.
You just can enjoy
high-impact, great storytelling
in smaller, shorter formats.
That's the plan.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well,
hopefully folks
will use the app for that.
How do you plan to grow
that as a business?
Is there going to be
a subscription model?
EKTA KAPOOR: It's a
subscription model.
It's-- for the
international Indian,
about $2 per month for the app,
which is way less than what
other channels pay.
And it's going to be
30 new shows a year
with a lot of top television
actors, film actors.
Lots of programming, of course.
Different languages.
And of course, the fun
part of this whole thing
is that I am not
looking at turning it
into profitable
venture the first year.
It's two, three years.
I think the moment you
start seeing the shows,
you'll know what-- I can't
even explain what I'm doing.
There's no way to say what
kind of programming it will be.
Will it be like "Kyo
Kii" or will it be
like "Dirty Picture"?
I'm like, it's going
to be a bit of both.
CLIFF REDEKER: It's
going to be-- yeah,
it's on it's own end.
Yeah.
And you know, your career in
the industry-- it's been 15,
20 years since you've started
making a mark on the--
EKTA KAPOOR: I
started 22 years ago.
CLIFF REDEKER: Yeah, so any--
EKTA KAPOOR: And that doesn't
have to speak about my age.
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF REDEKER: Started
when you were six.
So you've been through
highs and lows.
Like, obviously things
are very successful now.
You're expanding into new areas.
But there were times
that were more rough.
How did you approach
learning from some failures?
It's a tradition we carry
on here at Google as well.
EKTA KAPOOR: So, like from
being on top, 36 out of 50
shows-- I was in one year
without one show in top 50.
So, I mean, you just realize
that anything and everything
in life passes.
I believe in the
five ball theory,
which is that you've
got to keep juggling
the five balls of your life.
One is your family.
One is your love life.
One is your health.
One is your work, and
one is your own success.
And at the end of the
day, the only two balls
which are made of glass
is health and family.
So the others can fall.
They'll bounce back.
But these two, if they fall,
they never bounce back.
So I try to juggle
all the five balls,
but these two I see
that I manage better.
And career I realize one thing--
that you can do the best shows,
but it's success or
failures on your hands.
At the end of the day, you
should enjoy the journey,
take the set backs with a smile.
It passes.
Things keep happening which
are not in your control.
Sometimes a deal cannot happen
because there's been a global
meltdown.
Like, hello?
What did I do in this part?
CLIFF REDEKER: Right.
Right.
Things that are inside
your control and outside.
So you think you're
juggling pretty well today?
Or--
EKTA KAPOOR: I don't know
if I'm juggling pretty well,
but I constantly try to
see that I keep perspective
while keeping my
eye on the wall.
I still try to keep perspective.
CLIFF REDEKER: That's cool.
And then what would you say
your proudest moment has been,
apart from overseeing this
cricket league and everything?
EKTA KAPOOR: My
proudest moment--
I don't think I've-- I've had
a lot of ups and downs to have
any proudest moment.
But I think-- I've had
these days in my life
where I've been told that--
just moments at that time when
you look back at your life,
and you see you actually
started from a garage.
And you actually were somebody
that no one expected anything
from.
That makes you think, OK.
Not bad.
So I have really not
had any proud moment.
Because I really actually
collected just now after you
said, and I couldn't
even think of one.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well, it's
the journey, like you said.
It's just the hard work--
EKTA KAPOOR: It's just
great days and bad days,
and I think we all have them.
CLIFF REDEKER: So
what sort of advice
would you give to the next
generation of people entering
the industry?
EKTA KAPOOR: So I never
take my competition
as the big daddies or the big
global conglomerates out there.
It's always the new guy
sitting in the garage that
is the big, big fear.
Because he's the
man who's hungry.
He's the man with the new ideas.
He's the one who will
come in and revolutionize
the world again.
So he or she, whoever's
in the garage-- just
go ahead and do what you
want, because there is
no outcome that is guaranteed.
All you can guarantee is
that you enjoy the journey.
CLIFF REDEKER: And
I know you've tried.
I think we have time for maybe
one or two audience questions
if there's something
burning in your mind.
I guess we have one
up here in the front.
We have a microphone.
SPEAKER: Yeah, so there you go.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Ekta.
EKTA KAPOOR: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm Kavita.
EKTA KAPOOR: Hi, Kavita.
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question for you.
What made you pick
letter K for your shows
and move on to
other letters now?
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
That was on my list, too.
EKTA KAPOOR: OK.
So in India at one
time, a lot of people
thought it was only astrology,
which is a part of it.
Someone had told me
that K would suit me,
and I said if it's
working, why not continue.
After some time, it was-- I
did get couple of flops also.
And I was like, OK, now I
need to change the alphabet.
But then I said, what really
worked with the brand was
becoming synonymous with it.
People who couldn't even
understand English or Hindi,
or couldn't read-- I'm talking
about mass India-- could hear K
and knew it's my show.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
EKTA KAPOOR: And then it
became my own brand recall.
So I said, why change it?
Till there were so many spin
offs with the same letter
that the brand started losing
its fabric of personality.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
made its own version,
so then it was the
time to revamp,
like happens with any brand.
CLIFF REDEKER: Well,
just like here at Google,
we make our way
through the alphabet
when we name
versions of Android.
Now we have a
question in the back,
and then we'll cut
to the one up here.
So if you could
please pass that--
I guess we'll-- you're
closer on the list.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Hi, Ekta.
EKTA KAPOOR: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to find out
what did you feel about
[INAUDIBLE] then and now?
EKTA KAPOOR: So I feel
then she was smart,
extremely hard working,
extremely focused young girl.
Now I feel that she is an
extremely hard working,
extremely smart woman.
I think except for her
age, nothing has changed.
I keep meeting her.
She is the same.
AUDIENCE: That's nice.
EKTA KAPOOR: She
is extremely hungry
to do something to change
the universe, the world,
the country she lives in.
Which is when-- if you see
the way she has to act,
it was extremely forceful.
It was extremely passionate.
I think rarely do people who
conform or fit into boxes
make history.
I think she's one woman
who will make history,
so you won't find her following
anywhere the beaten path.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So we just
have time for one more
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Ekta.
My name is [INAUDIBLE] Moza.
I'll tell you one secret first.
There is an actor
inside every engineer.
I'm sure most of
them will agree.
And this is coming from somebody
who's acted in your "Kyunki
Saas Bhi Kabhi Bahu Thi."
EKTA KAPOOR: Really?
AUDIENCE: Question
is, when would you
start casting actors from US,
California, outside India?
EKTA KAPOOR: So part
of the app's function
is going to be
casting, where you
can upload an audition to me.
And we'll be putting
out the various--
so actually, I didn't
tell this, but I
did a lot of casting
through Facebook
and this-- people used to write
to me and ask to see them act.
And then, of course,
after it became well known
that I'd cast [INAUDIBLE]
through an audition I saw off
his-- which he just sent me
on FB, of course my account
crashed.
But I think it's the way
forward and, of course,
is going to be-- I'm
going to be setting up--
a big function of the app would
be a community that will be
of actors all over the world.
Because the whole idea
is if you're making sure
there are global
Indians, then you
want to be shooting
globally for them.
You need actors from
all over the world.
And I'm hoping to
launch lots of actors
from every part of the world.
There's going to be like
an audition put out,
and you just have to then
do an addition wherever
you are on your mobile and
send it, and you get cast.
CLIFF REDEKER: So that
means there's hope for me.
I need to download this app.
That's pretty amazing.
EKTA KAPOOR: I actually
think the world is becoming
like a big global
village, and stories
are going to be about
everyone living everywhere.
I think we're going to be far
more connected than we thought.
CLIFF REDEKER: So does this--
EKTA KAPOOR: And you
guys are helping.
CLIFF REDEKER: Thank you.
Yeah.
And so-- yeah,
we're pretty there.
You know I was voted the
best-dressed male at Google
Diwali 2013, so--
EKTA KAPOOR: Lovely.
Lovely.
CLIFF REDEKER: --that
passes the first round.
EKTA KAPOOR: I would
give you my vote.
CLIFF REDEKER: Oh, thank you.
So does that mean
you want to start
doing-- you're producing
shows in America
or will you stick with India?
EKTA KAPOOR: So I'm
actually shooting
a film in the next
few days in America,
shooting in New York, called
"Half Girlfriend" with Mohit
Suri, and Arjun, and Shraddha.
But yeah.
I would love to.
I mean, in fact I'm shooting
another show of mine which
is about-- which is on Star Plus
which is about two people who
fall in love.
I've heard so many
of these stories.
It actually started-- I
wanted to shoot it in Canada,
but I'm shooting in Austria now.
It started with this
dodgy taxi driver,
who was telling me how
he and his wife-- he
got married to a woman--
went, married her
in like a [INAUDIBLE] or
something and came here.
So that's the story.
It's about these two people
who are in a foreign land,
so it's actually an
[INAUDIBLE] show,
and how they connect with each
other in a totally alien world
and become a part of
each other's lives.
So that's my next show.
Actually, it's
called [INAUDIBLE].
It's coming on Starz,
so it's-- actually,
and the whole show is going
to be shot in Austria.
Because it's actually was
based first in Canada,
in [INAUDIBLE] family.
CLIFF REDEKER: Cool.
Very nice.
So we want to thank you
for stopping by today.
EKTA KAPOOR: Thank you.
CLIFF REDEKER: The app
coming out in November
on iOS and Google
Play, the whole deal.
And we look forward seeing
continued news of your success.
Thank you very much for
speaking with us today.
EKTA KAPOOR: Thank you so much.
CLIFF REDEKER: Thank you.
Ekta Kapoor.
[APPLAUSE]